foreign
exclusive Kelly Kelly is pregnant and we
have the photos of her growing baby bump
and I'm just like really come on yeah
the professional wrestler real name
Barbie blank is feeling amazing and for
Kelly and her husband Joe Koba the
moment is a long time in the making
selling E.T quote I've been dreaming
about this journey to Motherhood for so
long and starting a family with my
incredibly supportive husband when you
know you know the couples that I do in
2021. so Joe we talked about what I
liked and he went and got the most
amazing ring you guys it's so beautiful
for Kelly who's been open about her IVF
Journey the happy news comes after
tragedy two years ago Kelly experienced
a pregnancy loss her Mission normalized
IVF and fertility struggles I don't want
women to think they are alone I feel
like I'm fully grown I'm a woman now
This Is Me
by Kelly
when it comes to our pro wrestling
career Kelly is taking a break she tells
E.T WWE has always been great about
leaving the door open for me and now
she's wondering if that Gene runs in the
family maybe we will have a future
wrestler on our hands you know let's try
it let's see what happens three months
into her pregnancy Kelly admits her
first trimester was not so dreamy but
now I feel like I myself again and
overall it's been a great experience we
met here we've been together and now we
are moving into our dream home so
of course Kelly and Joe's biggest
chapter will begin on baby's due date
September 25th
[Music]